[Musique]
bienvenue dans le business club de
france des entrepreneurs nous sommes là
nous souhaitons vous apporter comme
chaque semaine des éclairages des bonnes
pratiques et des conseils durant cette
période compliquée aujourd'hui nous
allons nous intéresser au secteur de
l'agriculture michel picaud bonjour
bonjour fabrice bonjour à toutes et à
tous très heureux et encore merci aux
équipes de canal 32 de tellines concept
et de la fabrique de contenu de pouvoir
réaliser cette émission on peut à 10 ans
dans des conditions un peu spéciale en
tout cas édition spéciale qui je
l'espère vous sera très utile
aujourd'hui effectivement fabrice on va
s'intéresser au monde de agricole avec
didier cours il codirige de france
fabricant de matériel viticole et
vinicole dans l'aube mais aussi dans le
vaucluse
son entreprise fabrique notamment des
cuves pour les producteurs de vins et de
champagnes et puis nous irons à nîmes
pour comprendre comment le secteur
agricole évolue en ce moment ce n'est
pas simple
il y à des initiatives voir des
solutions très intéressante lady caron
qui a fondé à ce qu'a pu nous en dira
plus depuis nîmes
et puis c'est le moment aussi de
préparer notamment le futur en
conciliant les producteurs de vente en
les orientant plus vers la haute valeur
environnementale c'est l'occasion
peut-être de s'y mettre
une nouveauté dans cette émission le
rendez-vous de bp france avec patrice
bergues équipe on parlera aujourd'hui de
créations d'entreprises est ce le bon
moment et puis nous retrouvons le
médiateur des entreprises pierre
pelouzet pour de nouveaux conseils car
il faut savoir qu'il ya des pratiques en
ce moment fortement douteuses on vous en
dit plus à l'est direction neuville sur
seine dans l'aube pour retrouver didier
cours bonjour bonjour michel vaujour
fabrice di décor vous êtes le co
dirigeant de l'entreprise fmv de france
fabricant de matériel viticole vous êtes
basé dans l'aube mais aussi dans le
vaucluse
première question la vigne pousse
toujours même si dans le sud de la
france elle a bien souffert à cause de
la grêle mais elle pousse il y aura de
vin et du champagne en 2020 il faut de
la main d'oeuvre aujourd'hui et encore
plus certainement au moment des
vendanges en août et en septembre mais
tout d'abord comment vivez vous dans
votre entreprise cette période ça et on
a vécu le confinement déjà pour
commencer à partir du 16 mars au soir
pour le site d'epernay on a fermé un
mois complet pour le site on a un autre
site à neuville sur seine à côté de
bar-sur-seine on a fermé 15 jours
complets ensuite on a réouvert
progressivement on mettait en place
c'est évidemment dans les mesures de
protection
aujourd'hui à epernay en ami effectifs à
peu près évidemment il ya un trou dans
la raquette de production c'est pas
facile il faut s'organiser c'est un
phénomène nouveau
la vie reprend son cours on va dire
l'entreprise le 11 mai tout le monde
pratiquement sera de retour sur le pont
didier cours c'est compliqué pour le
secteur agricole et viticole en ce
moment davantage ma partie le secteur
viticole à nous on est installé heures
et on entretient le matériel le centre
de pressurage essentiellement mais ce
qui va un petit peu au tour donc
l'agricole c'est pas notre sujet
vraiment le viticole lui c'est compliqué
en ce moment les ventes sont roses sont
très basses 1 nous mêmes en tant que
partenaire des vignerons les l'activité
et basse on sait pas trop en fait déjà
2019 était une année un petit peu sur la
baisse la concurrence mondiale
il se vend beaucoup d'effervescence dans
le monde mais on n'est pas seuls au
monde
même si on a la particularité de la
champagne et que j'aime bien dire que on
peut déménager sur ces cépages mais pas
ses terroirs
mais pour autant ville c'est un moment
difficile pour la champagne où les
ventes sont faibles
merci didier cours restons dans le
domaine agricole et surtout ludique hall
direction à présent nîmes pour découvrir
ascap i avec sa fondatrice lady caron
bonjour bonjour michel bonjean fabrice
levis car on vous êtes ingénieur
agronome de formation 20 ans dans des
postes d'ingénieurs conseils puis chef
de service viticulture en chambre
d'agriculture avant à plusieurs
expériences au sein d'entreprises
privées dans le sud de la france est
aujourd'hui vous êtes consultante et
auditrices vous êtes à votre compte et
vous accompagnez les viticulteurs dans
leur démarche qualité le label hiv
août valeur environnementale c'est en
grande partie vous qu'il avait fait et
ça marche
première question comment se porte le
secteur viticole dans votre région je
rappelle dans le gard vaucluse 0
globalement en occitanie le secteur
viticole subi de plein fouet cette crise
comme beaucoup de secteurs économiques
en ce moment mais les difficultés
économiques liées au confinement sont
bien là les déclarons au delà du constat
les viticulteurs se sont adaptés comment
alors il s'adapte avec les limites des
règles du confinement qu'on connaît tous
aujourd'hui une de leur priorité c'est
quand même de garder le contact et le
lien avec leurs clients donc on a pu
voir ces dernières semaines une
accélération de leur présence en ligne
avec beaucoup de boutiques en ligne de
systèmes de dry de click and collect au
domaine dans les caves des livraisons
qui sont faites à domicile directement
par les vignerons donc beaucoup
d'innovation et d'adaptation mais ça ne
compense pas le manque à gagner dû à la
crise actuelle
donc le travail dans les vignes continue
oui mais avec les charges qui vont avec
et ne faudrait pas que ça dure
lady caron votre travail aujourd'hui
consiste bien accompagner ses
producteurs cette période est compliquée
ce n'est pas simple mais finalement
est-ce que ce n'est pas le moment de se
réinventer en termes de production en
misant sur la qualité du produit le vent
et avoir peut-être un avantage au moment
de la reprise
qu'est ce que vous leur conseiller
quelques est ce que vous leur dites la
viticulture s'est engagé depuis
longtemps fait dans la qualité des
produits c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau
j'accompagne depuis vingt ans des
vignerons qui s'engagent dans des
démarches qualité environnementale il
leur faut répondre à des exigences
importantes malgré les aléas climatiques
et les difficultés économiques qui les
touchent régulièrement
donc c'est une filière qui compte en
france un très grand nombre
d'exploitations qui sont sous label le
vignoble bio a triplé en dix ans la
haute valeur environnementale explose
aussi c'est une démarche récente ce
qu'on peut espérer c'est qu'après cette
crise les consommateurs eux seront
d'autant plus attentifs à tout ça dans
leur acte d'achat et chercheront à mieux
connaître et à valoriser ce travail qui
est engagée depuis des années
merci lydie car on sait leur déco région
on reste en occitanie pour découvrir
comment la région a mis en place un site
internet pour aider les agriculteurs
durant cette période de covin 19 un
exemple d'entr'aide interprofessionnelle
un reportage de via occitane et si
l'activité économique tourne au ralenti
la cause du coronavirus l'agriculture
elle ne peut pas attendre la fin de la
crise sanitaire
depuis l'interdiction des marchés de
plein vent les agriculteurs doivent
trouver des solutions pour limiter leurs
pertes au mieux pour répondre à la
demande à l'échelle régionale la région
si dany a créé une plateforme numérique
qui met en relation producteurs et
consommateurs
lancé le 24 mars dernier le site
internet favorise les circuits courts et
la vente directe
on doit être quasiment 3000 producteurs
aujourd'hui mars dernier on l'évoquait
nos producteurs s'adapte et imaginent
des solutions
un exemple dans les vosges maintenant
dans la commune de re ville aux chaînes
audrey élève des chèvres depuis un an et
demi et produit des fromages au sein de
la chèvrerie des chaînes elle a dû aussi
s'adapter la situation un reportage de
via vos jeux en effet avec l'épidémie de
kovy 19 les marchés en plein air ont été
suspendus et puisque la chèvrerie des
chaînes ne fait pas d'affinage
impossible de faire du stock sur la
longue durée
les fromages frais et autres yaourts
doivent se vendre en continu les voeux
alors dû trouver de nouvelles manières
d'écouler ses produits
on a mis en place des partenariats avec
les intermarchés donc de gérardmer
moyenmoutier j'ai ouvert plus le magasin
à la ferme du lundi au samedi de 10 à 12
à la place du samedi seulement
d'habitude et clients ils passent devant
il s'arrête
il va faire leurs courses ils passent en
même temps enfin voila c'est vrai que
c'est ça aide un petit peu à faire venir
les clients je fais aussi des livraisons
du fait les personnes ne passent une
commande et je livre en fin de semaine
généralement des points de vente variés
qui ont fait leurs preuves et caudry
souhaite conserver à l'issue de la crise
et pour satisfaire ses clients toujours
plus nombreux l'éleveuse songe à étendre
son offre avec de la glace au lait de
chèvre c'est le nouveau rendez-vous dans
le business club de france des
entrepreneurs le rendez-vous de bpi
france avec cette idée que tout ne doit
pas s'arrêter et la question du jour et
peut donc créer une entreprise en ce
moment patrice béghain bonjour michel
bonjour fabrice heureux de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui oui parlons
création créateurs tentez votre chance
on vous aide à la trouver en partenariat
avec les réseaux d'accompagnement à la
création d'entreprise et avec les
régions
nous informons préparons et orientons
les entrepreneurs et porteurs d'un
projet entrepreneurial
nous avons créé spécifiquement pour cela
un site internet dpi france création
point fr où l'on peut créer son pass
entrepreneurs et consulter toutes les
informations nécessaires à la création
d'entreprise via nos partenaires nous
soutenons et accompagnons la création
d'entreprises dans toute la france nous
proposons des financements du micro
crédit des prêts d'honneur de la
garantie bancaire mais également nous
proposons des dispositifs
d'accompagnement conseil coaching
mentorat accélérateur y compris dans
tous les territoires fragiles merci
patrice béghain seller maintenant du
rendez-vous du médiateur
pierre pelouzet bonjour quel est le
sujet de la semaine
pour le médiateur que vous êtes bon jean
michel bonjour fabrice alors ce soir
vous savez le comité de crise que je
pilote 1 qui regroupe l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'économie française se
penche régulièrement sur les problèmes
de retards de paiement sur le front des
retards de paiement on voit un petit
léger mieux en est pas encore revenue à
la normale loin de là mais on sort notre
action commence à porter ses fruits
malheureusement en parallèle nous
constatons la montée de nouvelles
mauvaises pratiques et je tiens à verte
et à travers de cette émission sur c'est
sur ces mauvaises pratiques et surtout
pour vous qui pouvait les subir
n'hésitez pas à nous faire remonter ces
cas à saisir le médiateur
je vais prendre quelques exemples qui
sont assez concret d'abord sur les
paiements
on constate un certain nombre de choses
d'abord retard pour faire des réceptions
c'est à dire que on prend du temps a
réceptionné les bien réceptionner les
services et donc du coup retard pour
pouvoir facturer et donc pour pouvoir
être payés en retard aussi dans l'envoi
des commandes
on demande un certain nombre de services
et puis les commandes arrivent de plus
en plus tard et donc là aussi les
factures arrivent de plusieurs plus tard
plus grave peut-être nous sommes
confrontés un certain nombre
d'entreprises de certaines grandes et
moyennes qui sont en train de demander
en espèce de rapport de force
des baisses de prix systématique
automatique transverses à tous leurs
fournisseurs et là vraiment il faut
réagir par rapport à ça autant peut
comprendre une discussion commerciale et
en particulier dans ces temps difficiles
on peut comprendre se mettre autour
d'une table et discuter pour voir
comment améliorer ensemble ces coûts
autant ces deux demandes imposé de
manière unilatérale et transverses ça
n'est absolument pas possible faut ne
pas hésiter à nous saisir là dessus on
agit déjà sur un certain nombre de cas
et on va continuer à le faire
ceci étant je ne veux pas m'arrêter
uniquement sur les mauvaises nouvelles
et je veux finir cette émission sur
quelques bonnes
vous le savez nous avons tendance et
volonté de mettre en avant des acteurs
positive des acteurs solidaires on a
déjà envoyé une liste il ya quelques
semaines de dix entreprises qui paient
leurs fournisseurs plutôt de
particulièrement les tpe
même les artisans on a quatre nouveaux
noms que je voulais mettre en avant
aujourd'hui que nous avons envoyé cette
semaine
il s'agit d'actions leur logement grt
gaz grdf et le groupe michelin
donc je tiens aussi à les féliciter et à
les promouvoir il faut que tout le monde
prenne exemple sur ces cas solidaire sur
ces cas emblématique et que de plus en
plus on pense à payer le plus tôt
possible ses fournisseurs surtout les
plus fragiles
merci pierre pelouzet merci michel et
merci à vous tous qui nous suivait
chaque semaine durant cette période
difficile
soyez courageux et retrouver nous chaque
semaine sur votre télévision ou radio
régionale ou bien encore en podcast à
très bientôt